hey what's up guys my name is a cello
and welcome to episode 79 of game
programming so it's gonna be a pretty
quick episode today I'm warning you
straight away probably say by the time
but we had a pretty long one yesterday
so I hope that made up for it but today
we're gonna talk about two things two
quick things the first one's not really
a thing it's more of a um just a quick
just a quick you know this isn't really
a new feature we're just gonna be
changing something around and that is
the spawner instead of adding it into a
static location on the level as you can
see if we launch our game right now we
get an explosion of particles over here
right next the player instead of adding
it here because that's kind of um well
let's just say it's just kind of looks
out of place we're gonna add it into a
different place so let's actually just
grab this entire add method and I'm
gonna cut that
ctrl X is the shortcut command X on Mac
and we're actually going to go all the
way into our player and in player in
fact not in player if we're gonna go to
that towards our wizard projectile so
into our wizard projectile dot Java
class because in this class that's where
we that's basically the projectiles that
we fire when we click so on collision
okay over here on the tile collision
what we're going to do essentially with
these particles is we're going to add a
new spawner on that location so level
dot add new spawner and let's import
everything but in control shift orb so
instead of this we have to put in level
and then everything's cool okay so
that's all you have to do so now if we
unless maybe drop this down to fifty so
if we take a look at this now when we
fire and there's a collision you can see
that it actually doesn't there's an
explosion of particles now obviously
it's happening in the wrong place right
now because we haven't changed the
values but um that's alright we can fix
that pretty easily
alright so if there is at all collision
and X&Y let's just make sure that it
actually Delta X now I think X is in
pixel Precision's was fine into it this
way so we'll add a new spawner at the
location X and y make sure we cast them
to an integer and we have an explosion
in x and y so let's take a look at what
that looks like and as you can see
that's really cool and you can adjust it
finally if you like but for the most
part we have an explosion of particles
when we collide cool there's a lot of
them and one thing you might notice is
they're not disappearing after a while
and that's sort of what we're going to
talk about now we have to set a life for
these particles because right now they
don't have a life literally they live
forever and that's a big problem both
from a performance point of view and
also of course aesthetically we don't
want 1 million particles floating around
if I do this for about two minutes
straight your games gonna look like this
pretty much forever now they do have a
speed so they do eventually move away
but still I mean you have these
particles creeping around and pretty
much no reason so let's get rid of them
the only boundary I guess that we have
to kind of work around is the fact that
the spawner is a universal class that
we've created ok and what I mean by that
is that not all elements that can be
spawned by the spawner have a life okay
some of them last forever like mobs or
last until they killed or until
something happens ok so because of that
we need we need to think of a way to
explicitly specify all ok we want to
give it a life of well I don't know 50
maybe 50 tics 50 updates yeah so to do
that there's several ways of doing that
but the best way I've thought about this
and the best way to probably do this is
actually to create specific spawn ins
for types that kind of renders our whole
mob and particle enumeration kind of
redundant but um we'll kind of work
around that here so over here in our
navigator or in your package Explorer
depends which one you use I personally
prefer the navigator because it gives
you a much cleaner Folds folder
structure here other than a bunch of
packages if we take a look here we'll
just have a bunch of packages it's not
really a hierarchy
whereas in navigator we actually have a
hierarchy system going on here
so under in entity I'm actually going to
make a new folder called spawner and I'm
actually just going to drag our spawn
under java class into that spawner
folder so of course a bunch of things
have changed I mean right here in spawn
and we basically just have to add doll
spawner because that's the folder that
we've moved it to and and she will have
to re important have to fix a lot of
imports you can see that our problems
here are the fact that our imports are
just wrong so control shift or it will
fix that in all the relevant classes and
you can see that we've gotten rid of the
majority of them there's one more in
spawn level for some reason I think we
use anything their degree anyway so now
that we've done that let's actually make
and use the new type of spawner okay
we'll make a spawner called a particle
spawner and hit enter and particles
burner will extend our normal spawner
again and this is gonna be a really
simple class okay there's gonna be a
really lightweight really simple class
we're not gonna add like too much code
in here at all what we are gonna add
though is we're gonna actually get rid
of type okay and we're gonna change the
type here to the spider we don't even
have to do that to type dot particle
okay and the amount will leave it
whatever the amount is obviously set at
but what we will add in here instead is
a life so into if-- we'll add to this
constructor and what we'll do is this is
actually where this stuff sort of
happens so this dot life equals life and
we'll set a life private integer live
over here okay so again what we're doing
over here is let's make sure the surfer
is our first of all what we're doing
here is insuring that we are actually
still using our current constructor with
type of particle everything's going
smoothly but we do we have set a life
here okay and that's very important now
if we go back into spawner the main
thing here that kind of changes is the
particle okay that's all we actually
need to do we just need to specify a
live particle
thing so what we can do is because we're
kind of overriding this constructor
let's actually just get rid of this
completely so instead of this if type
equals particle nonsense let's cut this
and let's move it into our particle
spawner now what I'm gonna change is I'm
gonna get rid of this type thing we
don't need that anymore and I'm just
going to set life over here and that's
really the only difference okay again
it's gonna do everything that the
particle class did which is sorry
everything that the spawner class said
which is not much at this point but
again we may add several things here
because bonus might be visual like for
example in Minecraft if you have like a
you know in a dungeon you have like am
an actual Kade at the spawns creatures
monsters I had spent forever since I
played Minecraft but you know that kind
of thing so they might be represented by
something and we'll put that stuff in
the spawner class but what we've made is
basically a type of spawner and that is
a bottle spawner so it's the same as an
almost bottle with the addition of life
okay sweet so now we've done that let's
take a look at how that will work so if
we check this really quickly so in other
words if we print over here when a new
particle is created lessers prints
particle life hello by the life of the
particle okay just a simple test here
just to see how this works and in our
projectile class or specifically our
wizard projectile class over here in
level dot add new spawn up let's change
it to level two add new particle spawner
and of course we don't need the spawner
type anymore but instead of and then
after the instead of the basically
instead of this instead of the type
we're gonna put the life so let's set
the life to maybe about forty for
specific number and make sure of course
that is indeed hang on us importers
first but make sure that that is indeed
the correct parameter and you have life
is the third parameter so that's correct
if we hit the start button on the debug
button and we do this we can see there's
a bunch of particles with the life of 44
so now that we've done this yeah the
next step is to actually make that 44 do
something so let's go back into particle
not the interface our particle class and
all we have to do here in update is
something very very simple
we need somehow count how long the
particle has existed for and if its
existence its span its lifespan is above
44 in this case or above the life that
we specify we need to remove it from the
level okay so the way we can do that is
just make a private integer here called
time and we'll set that equal to zero
because of all this are zero and here an
update would increment time now if you
want to be really specific here what you
could say is that if time is greater
than well let's just say a pretty big
number here well okay let's be
reasonable
integer dot maps value minus one in fact
let's just be safe and hit up minus ten
or something now let's calculate this
properly if time is greater than or
equal to integer to a max value minus
one but let's at time equal to zero and
again this is just a little test here so
that our game doesn't either run out of
memory or crash but it is a good
practice to implement something like
this usually we don't have to go up that
high because max value is absolutely
massive it can see it's see here one two
three one two three it's 2.1 billion so
that's pretty that's quite a big number
we definitely don't need to go up that
high but this is what this is what you
do if you want to be safe okay so let's
get rid of this and actually put in
something more humane so maybe about I
don't know I don't think we'll have any
particles that have a longer life than
7400 just met that Hummer up again so if
time is greater than or equal to 7400
we'll set it back to zero just to
prevent this initiative from becoming
overly huge if people decide to run the
game for robot or for some reason if the
life is huge again so if if our time is
greater than equal to some times 400
we'll set it back to zero but the idea
behind this is that if time
is greater than life that's where we
need to kill the particle okay and how
did how do we do that very very simple
in an TT if I go back to entity and it's
the first time I think we're removing
something so if I go back to our entity
class well you so over here is this
remove thing and all that does is said
removed equal to true now that doesn't
do much for us but if we set removed
equal to true we can then call this is
removed method and it will actually tell
us if the particles are removed or not
and from then on we can be like okay
well for all entities that have removed
equal to true let's actually to remove
them from the list and I don't think
we've done this before so I will um
leper an elaborate on this this isn't
going to be a short episode isn't it I
always say it's gonna be it's never
gonna be you guys know this is like me
like a broken record saying the same
thing every time and always letting you
down by giving you long episodes certain
or whatever okay so over here in update
in fact how this is in projectile in
particle in particle if time is greater
than equal to life we can simply remove
simple as that and that we're gonna be
near these brackets here let's keep it
clean let's keep it tasteful so if time
is red in the life remove simple as that
now now yeah we'll leave it like that
for now I was gonna handle this whole
thing but we will deal with her later
okay
so now let's take a look at implementing
this because I don't think we have the
best way to do this is in the update in
the level class okay so what we do over
here is we should really check for
particles that are dead or check check
for any entities that are dead and
actually remove them okay so I'm
actually gonna make a new method here
called private and void remove
essentially and it's gonna be private
again so it's not gonna get confused
with names or anything and we're just
want to run out over here okay so what
we'll do over here is because we've got
three lists which I'm not a big fan of I
might think of a better structure
than having three separate lists maybe
again a list inside a list is what I
mentioned last episode that wasn't joke
so if entity is what we can do over here
is for each of these entities
essentially if entities get AI dot is
removed is equal to true here then we
can actually remove or entities sorry
entities entities dot remove I okay so
what we're doing here is we're actually
removing in from the list and what
happens is when we remove it from the
ArrayList it has nothing else to do
right it's dead
and so what Java will do is actually
delete that object from memory
completely okay as long as of course it
doesn't it's not used anyway so Java
will take the hit
take care of that for us automatically
which is nice if this was say plus plus
for example you'd have to manually
delete that which isn't such a bad thing
at least at least you're sure it's gone
whereas the UM the collector of garbage
in Java can sometimes not collect the
garbage anyway projectiles dot get I dot
is removed so if it is removed then
entity sorry projectiles doll remove I
and same here so if if if particles dot
get I dot is removed oops
particles dot removers simple as that
now let's check let's take a look at
what that looks like
so if we do this after a while these
particles as you can see it disappear
now this is very boring okay I'm gonna
be honest here
this is quite boring these particles
just sort of disappear and well it's
cool and in fact they probably last a
bit too short I'd say they should
probably last longer but um that's
that's cool we'll fix that in a minute
so we'll get rid of this print line same
and first of all for this or printing it
that life is set to 44 this is this is
fine but the problem that I see with
this the one thing that I personally
don't like about this aesthetically they
all disappear at the same time that's
not cool okay
let's make this cool let's make them
slightly disappear at a random time how
do we do that
well glad you asked because what we have
to do here is actually basically add a
bit of variation to them so we'll still
keep life here but what we'll do is
we'll set life will actually add random
dot next int I was at a variation of
let's just say 10
okay so we'll add a variation of 10 to
the life so let's go 20 and then
subtract 10 which is half of that okay
so it'll choose around a number between
0 and 19 and what we'll do with that is
we're basically scrub-down from it so
within essentially what we'll get is
around and a random number from around
negative 10 to 10 okay it's probably
about negative 10 to 9 or something if
had it is negative 10 to 9 but to
positive 9 that's alright so let's take
this place take a look at this and now
we can say is they did disappear at
random times okay
now it might be a little bit hard for
you guys to see that so I'm actually
going to put it up here and maybe it's a
visit to 25 and sort of just make it
more obvious as you can see they do in
fact disappear random times and you can
play around with this you could set this
sum differently if you wanted to but I
think that's just a really cool feature
that you can do it doesn't take very
long and it's pretty this makes it look
nicer makes it look pretty ok so that's
how that works and that is how life
works for particles in our game
programming series in rain which is the
name of the game plus keep reminding
myself of that but anyway guys next time
we'll take a look at the maths behind
actually adding us as I said a floor to
these to this particle simulation so
that they can bounce off the floor and
actually look just a bit better than
just an explosion of particles and
random directions but um until then guys
I'll see you guys later
let's go back
you